DOND PERHAPS
RELITIGATE AGAIN.
ERIN?
>> EVAN,HAT'S GOM
PARLATORE,ORR TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP IN THE
IOFO WHITE HOUSELAWYER. MTO
HERE IN I  LEE NDE.VE PEOPLE A E
TO THINK THROUGH THICAREFULLY.T
REALLY READ THROUGH THISGA N
BECAUSE YOU WERE ON TH
ANDE
CATORNOF THISEN ALMOSTD ANTH
DOWN TO W WHAT IS EY HAVD WHEN I
EXCHANGES BETWEEESIDENT AUHE
VEBOXES.
>> RIGHTAGTHEYACAND YTHING
TO BEA  HURDLE.
THE OTHER THING IS THE
WILO PAC
>> RIGHT
DISSEMINATION.
C
THAT'S GNG POTENTILYS THAT, IT S
METHING
THAT IMOO MAILL WORK
FOR HIM.MEINTO B
E GOING TO HE TO FINOUA
>> I SHOULD BE CLEAR O
WHEN THETALK, THER
>> RIGHT.
TOT OF QUOTES
SA.S EN ED THA
MAN LLY WI BEEN UGAND AGAIN.WHAO
PICTURE, ANESS FOR VIRTUALLY
EVERRAATION IN
HERE.
THE -- ONAL PIECEE EVAN CORCORA
REPORTED IN HERED TH
THAT NAUTAINME
OING A AND I WAN O OF THESE POI.
CAN I FIRST JUSTAUSEOSE TO ER TN
IS
SAYS THAT WALT NAUTA WASG
DOCUMENTS  S
N CO
ATTORNEY NUMBE WOULD NOTD WOULEA
YOU VERYTHING.
AND, SO, IT WAS DETETHING LOAN
HAOUGHT, WOW, DO THEY REALLY
AND,CANDOR, I READ THAT
ANWAS WONDER
BECAUSE IF TY  HAD,
THAT I WOULD HAV
KNOW ABOUTARLIERETNG
PE U OE PRELIMARY S.
>> THEY DI T THING
THOULD'VE USED
>>RED OW YOU SAY IF THEYE IT
>>E MOVINGHINY BOXES AND THEN M.
HERENG IHA
WISH I COULD TEL M ON WHYDIDN G
U ANT  SAYFLIP?
>>AS
KNOWHAT TOLI KNOW WHE A PATRIO.
>> THEIGEREDS BEINUMS Y LOYAL T
AVE.
>> TY TO GET HIMO PROV TO JUST
AUTHENTICATE SOME OF THE
I DON'T OWIDN'T DO
IT THA
BUT IF THE AY ATO  ACCEPT ORO RL
AD SAD
AV
MOVING THE BN  TIM'S ESE ARE SON
ABOUT HIS AND ABOUT TH, WH
ENS GOG HY
S E AS I  W KNOWING
WH HAPPENED TO GO ASS
HERE WASINFO
E TO P
HAD SOM
T INFORMN.T ULE COME OUTVABE'RE
KNOWS.
THNTT CE
S  WAY TO REALLY RI T BEEN KE
REALLY, IT IS THE KIND OF THING
THAT W UTOT THAT INFORMATION BE
KIND ORTAINLT ND TO CHANIS
TEST TOP.F THE
SECUTO
OT USED N S EV FO I THI DEFIND L
TH WORKING  IT'PR
>> IS THERE ANYTHING TO
DI THIN TEAD BE
DETAILED AND THERE WE  PRESEN H
D
GI
EFFECY KNT
ALL , YO
PRETTYIVELY.E'S NO REASON TOW YR
YOU KNOUE PLAYMETH GO END INISME
T?NO PLEA OF GUIO NOIN>> I DON'
TO PLEA HERE.
CORCORORTANT IN
S NOTES.CTME.ARE A FEW THINGS TO
COMMUNICATIONS BETWEEN AN NEAWA
ATTORNEY AND CLIENE USR A FRAU.H
CE'S
AN V
HEN THFRAUD DECEIVEDIS
STGYF WHICE LAWYER
OFE HE DECEPTION
ION OFDEPANTND SO --Y, T
I'VE GIV YVEG, WHEN
,
INDICOXD BOXES. IID THE NOTES
CONVERSAH TRANS HAVING
TALKING T GETTING RI T
DOCUMENTS.
IF WN'D  OR WET  T
E JUST
NTS?
EXCHANGE HE HAS E TRUMP AT PINFT
NO CONTEXT, THOSE TIONS THERE,
CLASSIC ATTORNEY/CLIENT
EGEDTI'S WHERE A CO VER  IT CAN
DO.
GH
ISSING IY  ARE
THAT IT'S BEINNTS ACAL SPECIFIC
GO, WAS SAYING - BACK WHEN
DAD KENDALD 00
N ?'S THE CONTEXTEH
THESE.
AND WHENE
LIKE THAT WITH A CLIENT, WHICH
CLIENT --
>>Y THIS JUST
ANY CLIENT, THIS IS  VVPHISTICAS
DEALT WIAWYERS.
>> BUT HE L IS RECEIVINGEDERAL
AN ARYBOUTTHANAYE CAN'T   T CER
ERO E CLIENTS TO HAVE, LI
U K YOURESTIONO D
ERS NO I
GOIN USE THA PIERC
EGANEN CHARGE -- AFTERT IF THER
PROTOCOL.WHAT IOCOL I TO THAT G
HIM
TO DEVELOPATEGY ERYO GOING TCEE
TIDVICT --NTTHAT'SHE THIS ISED R
INCLUDED OR NOT. ARE.THE CORCORA
Y WERE ALLM STILL LEFTWALT NAUT
ESIT CORRAN
IN THET
THERE, HE STILL
HAVING THAT CONVERSATION WITH
THE PAC.
RS
YOU  CORRAOUT,STILL TEIB OF THE
THAT IF HAAN
, YOU  VSU DAMNINGS EY TO  HERE
THGSEVRAN.
YOU DO TO COMMIT
MIE GRAND
JURY.
YOU DON'T NEED T FEDERALJUDGESP.
YOU DON'NE T--OU THROW IN TWO T
THERE'S THAT WVED A
YOU DON'T NEED TO GOO A  ATTORNA
GAMES  D T
>> YOU DID JUST TH
THERE BU G
YOU THE FIWORD.
>> I THINK SIMPLSEHAT ISVE A MA
KILLED, YEAHYODON'T NEED ALL 17T
DIGNITUL